me it's irresistible a funny man is
irresistible more than any looks more
than any she was always a sucker for a
sucker for a laugh
I'm the best audience that's legendary
actor Gene Wilder and his third wife
Gilda Radner gushing over each other
when they sat down with et in 1986 Jean
died early Monday due to complications
with Alzheimer's and ET is taking a look
back at their romance she is my teacher
because she tells the truth more than I
do
when I am faced with a really tough one
where I I get hurt I withdraw into what
Gilda calls a dot and she will lambaste
me until I have the courage to get angry
with her respect her enough to get angry
with her and let her have it not in
order to punish her but to say what's
truly on my heart what hurt my feelings
because if you Harbor it it comes out in
another way but if you say it at the
time it's gone five minutes later it's
gone maybe the next day or possibly in
three years but it does go away 12 years
ago it wouldn't have worked at this
minute right here now specifically yeah
yeah we're happy yeah
a couple met while on set of their film
hanky-panky and married in 1984
tragically Jean lost Gilda to ovarian
cancer in 1989